well there are actually two movies I  remember seeing as a kid that were  really stood out one was the Wizard of  Oz which was really terrifying and  wonderful and exciting and and the other  was actually on the waterfront because I  remember Karl Malden played a priest in  that and I remember him coming into this  bar and Marlon Brando was saying  something to him and he he told more  than Brando to go to hell and that was  the most shocking thing I think I've  ever seen where a priest said go to hell  Chris today that wouldn't be that  surprising but but it was really amazing  but yeah those were really powerful  experiences for me as a kid